KYLE SIMPSON: I'm Kyle Simpson,
and we are the honored panel
that's been chosen to speak
to you while you are gradually
lazing into your food
comas after lunch.
So we're pretty
excited about that.
We'll try to keep it
lively and fun today,
and hopefully my
goal is that there's
at least one chair thrown,
but we'll see how that goes.
OK.
So I-- my names--
probably most people
know me as getify online.
I'm an open web evangelist.
I teach JavaScript, and
I write about JavaScript.
I've got a series
of books on it.
So that's a little bit about me.
But I wanted to quickly
introduce my panelists,
because they're actually
the experts on the topic.
So over here to my far
right, your far left,
is Matt Miller, co-founder
of Lapwing Labs, correct?
And he told me in
his introduction
that he really loves open
source, which is great.
He loves travelling,
he's a big fan of SVG.
Any SVG fans in the crowd?
Yeah, all right.
And I guess most favorite
of all, he loves Docker,
and many of us can also
identify with that.
So welcome Matt Miller.
MATT MILLER: Thank you
KYLE SIMPSON: To his
left, we have David Beck
who founded Rotunda or
just worked for Rotunda?
DAVID BECK: Yes, founded.
KYLE SIMPSON: Founded
Rotunda Software.
I thought-- I thought
that was true.
He's worked on a software--
it's an asset pipeline build
tool called Cartera
so we'll definitely
want to keep the difference
between build tools and package
managers-- they can
kind of overlap--
but we want to keep
those separate.
But he's built a tool
in the build tool space.
He told me that he's most
passionate about burning IE8
to the ground, and
I think most of us
can agree that's a pretty good
thing to be passionate about.
All right.
And then we have Josh Peck.
JOSH PEAK: Peek.
KYLE SIMPSON: Peek, sorry.
Pardon me.
Josh Peek, works for GitHub.
And I want everybody
to cheer and applaud
because he helped write the
side-by-side diffs feature that
just launched on GitHub.
[CHEERING]
KYLE SIMPSON: And
I think could be
one of the most amazing
things that's ever happened
in GitHub's history so--
but also in that same token,
when I asked him to
tell me about himself,
he wrote a very tiny
letters, "I work for Bower."
So we'll hear, I guess, more
about that on our panel today.
And then over here on
my left, your right,
we have Laurie Voss,
who is the CTO of npm.
And Laurie wanted to make
sure that we remind everyone
that npm is spelled
lowercase, and it is not
an acronym for anything.
Keep that clear.
But more seriously, I found
him in our conversations
to be very reasoned and
thoughtful about evolving npm
to serve the needs of the
collective developer community,
so we're glad to have him.
And finally, last but not least,
Dominic Denicola to my left.
Dominic works for Google,
he's on the Chrome team.
He spearheaded the ES6
Promises-- by the way,
thank you so much for that.
Promises are awesome.
[CHEERING]
KYLE SIMPSON: He is
also a contributor
of controversial features to
npm such as peer dependencies.
So we can all thank
him for that as well.
And he's the foremost authority
on Star Wars: The Old Republic.
So maybe if we have time
in the overflow session
we can talk about that.
But he will also open
us up now with the set
up of what package
managers are and why
we should be caring about them.
So I'll turn it over to Dominic.
DOMINIC DENICOLA: Thank you.
I'm kind of wishing I made
this a Star Wars-themed package
management intro, but
I didn't so oh, well.
So to me, the way I try and
approach the package management
space is to think
about really what
we've done as a community with
the web over the last ten years
or so.
Because I don't
know about you guys,
but I used to be very
proud, back in fifth grade,
to call myself a webmaster.
All right?
And so times have
changed a little bit,
and now we try and think of
ourselves as a little bit more
like software engineers.
And I know, personally, getting
out of school and reading all
these books, you know, "Patterns
of Enterprise Application
Architecture" and "Domain-Driven
Design" and "Refectoring"
and so on.
The things that keep
coming up over and over
again are topics like modular
architecture and separation
of concerns and proper
ways of code reuse
and structuring your code.
And so kind of the first
level of these patterns
and this modularity
idea is modules.
And in JavaScript,
I'd say we got this.
Right?
Like, we've figured
out how to do modules
and maybe you're
trying to decide
whether you want to wrap your
modules in a defined wrapper
or you don't or if you want to
use syntax or just functions,
but that's not, like,
the most important thing.
The most important
thing is that we all
understand we
should be separating
our code into modules, and
nobody is dropping script tags
into their body anymore--
or worse, into their head.
So the thing to
understand about modules--
we've got this, right-- is they
let you reuse your own code
and maybe work within
your own project
and reuse other people's
code on your team.
But we need to go
to the next level.
And that's where
packages comes in, right?
So packages let you reuse
code written by somebody else
and packaged up and distributed
for you as a third party.
And so there's
several key concepts
when you're talking
up package management
that you want to keep in mind.
So the package is
a set of files,
and usually with some
metadata about the package.
Things like the name, the
version, the description,
and the dependencies,
which is important.
Then there's the
registry concept,
which is where you put those
packages on the internet
so that you can go
and install them from.
And then finally,
you have the idea
of a package manager,
which is something
that allows you to install
packages from the registry
onto your local machine for
your apps and your development.
And crucially, also, a
package manager's role
is to install the
dependencies of a package
that you want on your machine.
And this is great
because it encapsulates
the details of how
a packages is built.
So if Ember, as a package,
depends on the route recognizer
package, when you
say, install Ember,
or whatever your favorite
package manager is,
you don't care about how
it implements routing.
But it says, oh, I need route
recognizer to get my job done.
So that gets taken care of for
you by a good package manager.
So in terms of package
managers and packages
and the whole ecosystem,
this is not a new idea.
Right?
We have this stuff in all
these other ecosystems,
and we have it in
node for JavaScript.
It's really crucial
for code reuse
and so every mature language
and ecosystem has them.
However, on the web, we're not
so sure what our answer is.
And that's one of the reasons
that we're here today.
I mean, we've figured it out
for server side JavaScript
with npm, and some
people, myself included,
think that we should be using
that for all JavaScript.
But other people
don't, and that's
kind of one of the things
we want to talk about.
So I think kind of going
into the whole discussion,
there are still areas
specifically about the web
and package managers
that, to me, are complex
and we need to think
about together.
And so what makes the web
in particular a hard problem
to solve for package managers?
Well, first, there's,
like, how related
are packages to modules?
Right?
Some early package managers,
things like volo or Jam
bet on amd.
Others these days,
like Component and Duo,
bet on common js.
Bower has a mix. npm has a
strong common js community,
but it doesn't actually
mandate common js
in any way intrinsically.
And, of course,
some people think
ES6 modules will save
us all and that's
what's going to make package
management work finally
for the web.
And so depending on
your perspective,
I think modules and packages
can either be totally unrelated
and it's just one of the
things you put into a package
or they can be
entirely intertwined.
Another issue that
comes up on the web
is different asset types, right?
So we all pretty
much understand how
to put source code
into a package.
We've done this both in
node and in other ecosystems
and other languages.
And that's great because
that's pretty easy.
There's no complexity
in just one language.
But when you have the web, you
have at least three languages.
So you have HTML,
CSS, and JavaScript.
And you've got fonts
and images and all that.
And so this gets complicated
because things like CSS
have a global effect, unless
you're using web components.
Or like fonts definitely
have a global effect,
and there's not really
a way to encapsulate
that unless you
rename them, right?
So does this change how we think
about package management is
my question.
Kind of this plays into the
question of reduplication
and how this plays into
semantic versioning, which
is a big, big issue that divides
kind of some of the package
managers today.
So, like, what if one
of your dependencies
wants to use package
foo at version 1.0,
and another wants to use
package foo at version 2.0.
Now, remember I said that part
of the idea of the package
manager is to encapsulation
you from worrying about what
your dependencies are using.
But should we allow duplicates
to exist in your source tree?
And maybe you say, no,
because you should never
have duplicate code on the web.
But does your answer change
if it's a 30 byte number
formatting thing?
Like, does that work?
Or what about if it's
jQuery 1.0 versus 2.0?
Well, that's kind of
a different story.
Or what about if it's something
like underscore or backbone
that doesn't even use semantic
versioning at all so you have
no signal for whether you
should be including these two
different things?
I mean, this is a pretty hard
question answer, I think.
And it's kind of
at the core of some
of the disagreements between
web package managers.
Finally, there's the issue
of web components, right?
Which in some ways
make things better.
They give you an
encapsulated, packaged up,
reusable component.
And in some ways
they make it worse,
because they share this global
flat name space of tag names.
Unlike the kind of idea in
JavaScript where you can say,
I'm going to include
another JavaScript file.
And it's not going to
interfere if it's well-written,
it's a module.
With web components, I reserve
this tag name for myself.
And then to complicated it
all, as part of web components,
you have this HTML
import technology.
Remember how I said that nobody
these days is putting script
tags in their head
or their body?
Well, instead what they're
doing is they're putting link
rel="import" tags in their head.
So we're back in the '90s
with HTML imports, which
is interesting.
So that's what I got on kind
of the big issues of package
management on the web.
And ready to go.
KYLE SIMPSON: Awesome.
Well, thank you very much.
Let's thank Dominic for that.
[APPLAUSE]
KYLE SIMPSON: I think
that's a fantastic way
to set up where
we're going to go.
There are so many
different directions
that we could talk about, and
we had to narrow them down.
But I just want to remind
everyone if you had forgotten,
there is a breakout session
later this afternoon.
And so if we have to cut things
off or if we skip over a detail
that you think is
really important,
please do come and find us
in those breakout sessions.
We'd love to chat more.
Just last night at dinner,
just one of these few questions
that we're going to go over,
we spent an hour or more
talking about it.
So there's lots to talk
about, lots to dig into.
Without any further ado, we'll
go to our first question.
And our first question says,
"which of the characteristics
are important for package
managers to focus on?"
so let me give you
some examples, panel,
to set this up.
Some examples like package
creation, maintenance overhead,
curation, how do we
know that the code there
does what it says
it's supposed to do
and that it's going
to be good quality
and not harm the systems,
discoverability, and even
responsiveness of the teams.
These are issues that we deal
with in the package manager
ecosystem.
So let's talk about
which ones are important.
And importantly, actually, I'll
throw out this first to Josh
since you do have some
experience on Bower.
How well are the
package managers
doing on these
different metrics?
JOSH PEEK: Well, I do say, I
think the one difference-- I
do like the difference that
Dominic has broken down
in terms of the concerns that
these things are doing with,
like, publishing the registry
and the actual, like, install
tool.
So I think Bower is interesting
in that it doesn't actually
have any publishing mechanism.
It just-- you put it on the web.
It's just on the
web via a git URL.
So that's just handled however
using existing git tools.
And the registry is
super lightweight
so it's more along the
lines of the build tool,
and so you kind of-- it's kind
of dependent on the existing
ecosystem, like GitHub, in terms
of how we discover these things
and maintain them.
And I think primarily Bower
is the tool end of it.
Like, how do you, like,
download all these dependencies,
resolve dependencies,
and deal with that.
KYLE SIMPSON: It's interesting
that you would say,
because I think many people
would probably put Bower firmly
in the same category
as something like npm.
I certainly would as a user,
because there's a command line
tool that I have
to do, and I have
to manage a bower.json file.
So can you tell me-- maybe you
guys can kind of fight over
this-- but why are
you different then?
If Bower really isn't
quite in the same category
as npm what is that--
because as a developer,
it sure feels like
they're a lot the same?
JOSH PEEK: I don't know.
I think the flow-- I mean, I
think the Bower flow definitely
feels easier to publish
as opposed to npm.
But there's definitely benefits
to having a separate package
that you can, like, publish.
Like, Bower doesn't actually
have a good story for,
like, how it's doing mirrors and
replication like npm does this.
KYLE SIMPSON: So
what about Laurie?
npm is bad for publishing?
[LAUGHTER]
LAURIE VOSS: npm is
just a lot more--
it does a lot more stuff.
I was going to say it's
a lot more heavyweight,
but I don't think that's
the word I want to use.
npm has decided a bunch
of things are important.
It's decided that you
want to be able to publish
a single artifact and say
that that artifact is there
an constant forever.
And you want to be able
to-- you know, the mirroring
and replication you sort
of get for free by accident
of the database that
we use, but it's more
about we want all this
metadata attached.
We want a delivery
mechanism established
that is not the same as our
source control mechanism.
DOMINIC DENICOLA: I think
that's really important.
I think committing your build
artifacts to your source
control just so that they can
be consumed by a package manager
is really unfortunate.
And it's something that's
prevented me from having Bower
in projects where
people asked me to.
It's like, no, I'm not going
to commit my compiled--
JOSH PEEK: What's the
disadvantage of that though?
Like, what's the disadvantage
to having them in source code?
Like, actually merging
them, what are you losing?
DOMINIC DENICOLA: Oh, the
ability to keep my source
separate from my output.
JOSH PEEK: So you can--
DOMINIC DENICOLA: It's like
committing .exe's to your repo.
You would never do that.
JOSH PEEK: You can
have different repos,
different branches.
Like, what are the
other downsides?
DOMINIC DENICOLA: Right.
You could set up-- you could
use git as a package repository,
but why would you?
DAVID BECK: And the
big-- I mean, let's not
lose sight of the big picture.
npm is the node package manager.
So if you want to
use node packages--
DOMINIC DENICOLA: No.
[LAUGHTER]
DAVID BECK: Or-- I'm sorry.
KYLE SIMPSON: It's
not the acronym.
We got that out of the way.
DAVID BECK: It's
the only package
manager you can use with node,
or the people use with node.
So if you want to use-- so
it has that feature of it.
And Bower is very much more of
a client side package manager.
It has inclined
itself or people are
inclined to use it for
client side packages.
And just to be-- I want
to sketch this out,
you guys can agree
or disagree, but it
seems like there are few
different layers of packages
and the landscape is as
such there's service side
packages, which are
handled by npm exclusively.
There are client side
JavaScript packages,
only JavaScript packages,
which are handled by npm
and also by Bower.
There are packages that have
CSS and other assets in them,
and they're client
side packages.
And those can be handled by
npm with Cartera, for example,
but they're mostly
handled, I think,
by Bower-- also by Component.
And then you have web components
below that, which nobody really
knows how they're going to
handle it at this point,
but it's looking like
it's going to be Bower.
And then there's
just CSS packages,
which I think is another level.
And that is mostly
handled just by Bower.
KYLE SIMPSON: So I'm
sorry to jump in,
but I want to refocus
this on the specifics.
Because-- Matt, let
me throw it to you.
Can you talk about
maybe one or two
really important characteristics
of the package manager
of your choice or ones that
you maybe have worked with.
What are they doing?
What are the most
important things
that they should be focusing on?
And maybe some areas
that they're not
focusing enough yet.
MATT MILLER: Yeah.
So I created Duo basically
because I wanted a way
to pull in any source, any
code from anywhere, basically.
That was the idea.
And have it build for you.
And I think we're talking a
lot about the installer being
different from
the builder, and I
would argue that that's
not necessarily--
it doesn't necessarily
have to be different.
And so a lot of what
Duo does is basically
you can install from
literally anywhere.
That's the goal, anyway.
Right it's from GitHub,
but eventually it'll
be from anywhere.
Like, you can basically
go to any site,
you can take a look at
where they're including,
and then require it immediately.
And so that's kind of the goal.
And I guess the other
thing that-- so,
like, basically, ease
of use is probably
one of my most important things.
And the other thing
is reproducibility.
So basically being able to
build something and then
be expected to, like,
six months later,
build that same thing again.
And I can't say Duo
has an answer to it.
I don't think any of the
other package managers really
do it very well.
But I think that's--
LAURIE VOSS: npm
tries very hard.
MATT MILLER: npm
tries very hard, yeah.
KYLE SIMPSON:
We're going to take
a couple of comments
in just a moment.
I want to let you
elaborate a little bit more
in npm's defense, but we'll take
comments from Sarah and Rachel
so if we can queue them up,
let's make sure to do that.
But tell us, what is npm
doing in your own defense?
LAURIE VOSS: So npm--
this is something
I've been discussing with
a bunch of people today.
npm has multiple roles.
Like, when you are
npm installing,
are you npm installing because,
I want this software so that I
can play with it and
build my application?
In which case, it is a dev tool.
Or am I npm selling because
I am deploying this to a box
somewhere.
In which case, why am I
installing my tests and my docs
and all that stuff like that.
There's a difference
between a build artifact
and a package of software.
And at the moment,
npm is definitely
optimized for the latter
of those two use cases.
But people keep trying to
use it for the other thing.
So we are starting to
support that better.
The shrink wrap feature of
npm is, sadly, neglected
and was, until quite
recently, unusable
because it was possible
to publish version 1.1.1
and then publish
[? dash F ?] 1.1.1 again
and have it be a completely
different bit of software,
which just breaks
that whole idea.
KYLE SIMPSON: OK.
Let's take--
LAURIE VOSS: You
can't do that anymore.
KYLE SIMPSON: A comment.
Is this Sarah?
SARAH: Hi, I'm Sarah.
So going back a bit.
You mentioned generated
code and checking that
into version control.
That's been a big problem for
me and my teams, personally
so I generally strongly
advocate against doing it
because it causes all
sorts of merge issues.
I wanted to see what sort of
solutions you guys had in place
for deploying generated code
and just managing that process.
DOMINIC DENICOLA: Yeah,
I mean, briefly, I
think the answer from npm's
perspective is very clear.
Your package contains
the generated code,
your source repository
contains the source code.
And as part of the
pre-publish process,
you generate and then you
put the generated code
in the package.
LAURIE VOSS: Or you build it as
part of your install process,
as opposed to install hook.
KYLE SIMPSON: So
Josh, I know you
happen to have a slightly
different perspective on this.
Tell us why GitHub
and those tools
allow you to manage all of
that crazy merge nightmare
that Sarah was talking about.
JOSH PEEK: Well, yeah.
I'm definitely of the approach
if you're deploying something
to reduction, you want to limit
your third party dependencies.
Like, you don't want to
depend on npm being up
or some other server being up
during your deploy process.
Like, having some other host go
down shouldn't take you down.
So, like, I think it just
makes sense to check in as many
of those artifacts as you can.
If it's something-- the
burden of doing that, I think,
is a lot less than having
a availability dependency.
KYLE SIMPSON: Is
Rachel out there?
Rachel?
Did we get a
microphone to Rachel?
Yes?
No?
OK.
Do make sure you raise
your hands whenever
you're going to ask a question.
RACHEL: I was going to
specifically call out
when we're talking about build
artifacts versus source code
the multiple vectors of images,
CSS, HTML, and JavaScript.
In package management
versus build system,
separation works
a lot better when
you've got a close link between
module source code and package,
where you're only
importing one thing.
It's just not really
working well when
you have all these other assets.
KYLE SIMPSON: Yeah.
So definitely.
Thank you for your comment.
We definitely are
planning to tackle
this idea of other resource
types other than JavaScript.
So we'll come back
to that and revisit
that topic in a little bit.
I want to switch now
to our second question.
Our second question is going
to go a little bit deeper
so we're going to uncover sort
of this holy war, this debate
that's actually happening,
whether we articulate it
as that or not.
And that question is what
are the relative benefits
of specialized package managers?
In other words, should we be
having a new package manager
with every framework that comes
out versus one package manager
to rule them all?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
KYLE SIMPSON: Thank you,
Brian LaRue, for that comment.
DOMINIC DENICOLA: So to me
the biggest most important
benefit you can get from a
package manager is the network
effects of reusing a
large package ecosystem.
So I mean, earlier they
brought up the different types
of packages being put in
different package managers,
to me, I'm most
interested in the overlap.
What is the JavaScript
code I'm writing?
That it doesn't
matter whether it
runs on the server
or the client,
and I can just reuse
it in either case.
And if you're saying, oh,
I have to make a choice
whether this goes
in my client package
manager or my server package
manager, that really impacts
and limits my ability to do
code reuse in the general case.
And in general it's
very frustrating
to say that I must
make that choice.
I'd rather have a
JavaScript package manager.
LAURIE VOSS: So npm gets-- one
of npm's most common feature
request from everybody
else is can you
please build
whatever feature x is
that is forcing me to use
this as their package manager?
Can you please just
make npm do everything?
Like, we were
joking the other day
that npm has now become the way
that you install other package
managers.
DOMINIC DENICOLA: Which is true.
LAURIE VOSS: Right.
You at npm just install all
of the other package managers,
and we're like, fine.
That's what we do now.
I think what npm
is moving towards,
like as we discussed
last night, is
instead of saying--
picking one way and saying,
this is how you do it,
npm is going to say,
here's a bunch of
things that we can do.
By default, this
is how it works.
If you want to change one
aspect of this process,
don't rebuild the package
manager, we will modularize.
And you can use steps
one through five
and change how step six works.
And npm will enable
that behavior.
That's how we would prefer it.
Like, no one is going
to radically change
storing bits on a server.
Like, that's going to be
the same no matter what.
What changes most often is
how you install the bits
once they land on your server.
KYLE SIMPSON: So
that's a great way
to articulate the
eventual-- you know,
there's package
managers everywhere,
but there's one set of
code that's running it.
Which is fine, but
I feel like I want
to represent sort of the more
common man approach to this.
The rent-is-too-damn-high
approach,
because it's too damn difficult
to manage all of my packages
and all of my meta data across
all of those different things.
So what about that?
What about this idea that maybe
one day there is just one,
and there's a dash dash
Bower flag instead of npm?
DAVID BECK: What?
Just one what?
For which of those areas?
Like, because there are
different overlapping
areas here.
So one package manager
for which of those?
Clearly the CSS, if you're
just managing CSS packages,
that's not really JavaScript.
And it seems that these sort
of package manager monopolies--
natural monopolies-- happen
on a given language, which
we don't have right now.
But CSS is not JavaScript,
and web components, I think,
arguably are not really
JavaScript, either.
It's more like
their HTML and then
they have JavaScript
inside of them.
So just to be clear.
I mean, for me the
ideal situation
would be to have npm working
the server side, the client
side, JavaScript, and the
component-ish JavaScript
where you have JavaScript
components that
also have CSS and HTML assets.
KYLE SIMPSON: So your vote is
more for the single package
manager eventually?
DAVID BECK: Does anybody vote
for multiple package managers?
I mean--
KYLE SIMPSON: I think
a lot of people do.
So that's what we're trying to--
MATT MILLER: So one thing
I would like to point out
is the concerns are a bit
different in the client
and the server, and one of
those concerns is file size.
And so one example of this that
comes to the top of my head
is trying to make
Cheerio or something
like that work in the browser.
And you end up-- like, Cheerio's
great on the server side,
but you end up with a bunch
of artifacts and stuff.
Like, you end up with
like a 300 kilobyte file
that you're basically
loading onto the browser.
And so I would argue that it's
good for the server, but not
necessarily a good
idea for the browser.
And having a single
package for that is not-- I
don't think that's ideal.
DAVID BECK: Well, they can
do one for the server and one
for the browser.
MATT MILLER: Yeah,
it's possible.
KYLE SIMPSON: So
let's bring Bower
into this a little
bit more explicitly.
If we go back a couple of years
to the history of where Bower
sprung up, at least
my understanding of it
is that Bower was springing
up because there was concerns
that npm wasn't serving some of
the needs that they needed to.
So speak to that specifically.
What's missing from some of
these package managers that
required the specialization?
JOSH PEEK: I think one of
the things that started off
was that the way to do
it on npm, if you wanted
to do front-end packages,
was to essentially do
what Browserify is doing today.
And it didn't really encourage
any other sort of, like, paths.
Like, people were doing web
component-ish things before.
And that doesn't quite fit into
how common.js modules work.
So I think the idea
was that we would
have a more open system that
was, like, decoupled from build
tools, and the package manager
would be, in some sense,
dumber.
And, like, you can
have build tools
that can operate on AMD, CJS,
and then future ES6 modules.
KYLE SIMPSON: So I'm
going to give you a chance
to respond that he just called
your package manager dumb,
but we'll take a comment from--
JOSH PEEK: Yeah, I think
I called myself dumb.
KYLE SIMPSON: We're going to
take some comments from Patrick
and Taryn.
So if we could get
their microphones.
But what about that?
Do you see that the
specialization is just
layering of the package
manager that there's
different parts of
the package manager
that handle these
different concerns?
LAURIE VOSS: I think I'm
close to what Dave said.
I think there's a very
open question as to
whether-- because npm is the
package manager for node,
can npm be the package
manager for client side stuff?
Because npm can be the package
manager for JavaScript,
I think.
I think that would
be easy, but that's
not what people want to be.
People want it to
be the way that I
install a widget
into my application.
And the concerns
of pure JavaScript
versus how do we do client
side stuff are sufficiently
different that it's
definitely not resolved,
like, within npm's
offices whether or not
that's a thing that we
can eventually nail.
Or whether or not that
is a different thing.
DAVID BECK: You
can nail it, but I
think you lose some
of the elegance of npm
where everything
just works mostly,
except for maybe
peer dependencies.
But inside the world-- I'm
not-- I don't mean that lightly.
I mean there's some things
that are complicated even
in the pure JavaScript
world but not many of them.
But in the CSS world, it
does become more complicated.
But that doesn't mean that
the value that you would bring
by tackling that niche
of JavaScript modules
inside the browser doesn't
outweigh the added complexity.
KYLE SIMPSON: So
Patrick do you have--
does Patrick have a microphone?
There we go.
PATRICK: Dominic mentioned
the, like, great network
effective of npm
and how it's great
that you can pretty
much find anything just
by npm search, et cetera.
The issue is that you have
no idea whether or not
that'll actually
work in the browser.
I don't know if I'm going
to have to Browserify this.
Or even after that, if it work.
Whereas with Bower, generally
it's either completely broken
or it does work to some
level in the browser.
LAURIE VOSS: We have such
a great answer for that.
That's been a repeated
question, especially
from the Browserify people
and various other people
doing browser stuff.
The new version of
the npm website,
which is currently being
busily worked upon,
has the concept of
ecosystems where
we have said that people don't
use npm for one thing so trying
to lock everything into a single
concept of search and a single,
like, metric of what
is best is impossible.
So ecosystems are basically
slices of the registry.
So you'll in some way tag
or have a programmatic way
of recognizing that
this package is
compatible with this ecosystem,
and it will get automatically
included into this search.
So you can say,
search only for things
that are going to
work in a browser,
and tell me what they are.
Search only for the things
that are good for robots.
Search only for the
things that work
for this particular framework.
DOMINIC DENICOLA: OK.
And I think that's
really powerful,
because you can have things that
work with Browserify, things
that work with RequireJS--
if people still use that.
Things that work with web
components, in particular.
Things that tie into
that global registry.
And so that way you can say,
OK, well, two web components
have the same tag name, I guess
I shouldn't use those together.
So this ecosystems concept,
I'm really excited for it
to land because then it will
be-- everything will be better.
KYLE SIMPSON: Taryn?
Are you out in the crowd?
There we go.
TARYN: So I for awhile built
a build tool around Bower.
So how do kind of think of--
KYLE SIMPSON: Let's
make sure we don't
stray into extra questions.
We can tackle those
in the other session,
but did you have
a point that you
wanted to make about
difficulty with that?
TARYN: Yeah.
It's you don't really
know what you're
going to get when you get-- when
it's downloaded from GitHub.
And so this week it
might be copy script
pre-compiled, next week it might
be in a different directory
where the copy script has
been pre-compiled, too.
Or maybe it's not
pre-compiled at all
and now you have to figure out
what language this package is
in, this particular
git commit dash.
And I didn't know,
like, what tooling
you plan on putting around
that so you have a better
idea of what you've
actually installed
and how you can use it.
KYLE SIMPSON: I think
to Dominic's point
about the package being
more about built assets
that are ready to deploy
more than source, that
can begin to address
those things.
But certainly it's up to each
individual authorized, right?
To--
DOMINIC DENICOLA: Yeah.
Yeah.
And I think that's the thing,
is it's really cultural.
At npm there is a
strong cultural bias
towards JavaScript,
not copy script.
If you want to write copy
script you pre-compile it first.
And honestly towards
common js modules.
And I think that common
js models, especially
as we go towards ES6 and
whatever, will be challenged.
But I think it is great to
have a convention that we don't
publish copy script
to the registry.
And you could if you want, but
I think it's nice that we don't.
KYLE SIMPSON: OK.
So I suspected that that
first question might not
get as specific as I wanted
to, particularly on one topic
and that is the
challenges of metadata.
So our third question that we're
going to go to is specifically
what can we do-- so let me make
sure I read this correctly.
What can package
managers and developers
do to streamline the overhead
of package metadata, especially
across multiple
package managers?
LAURIE VOSS: Just stop
using other package manager,
obviously.
KYLE SIMPSON: That's the obvious
softball answer, but let's--
DAVID BECK: Or just give each
package manager the domain.
A clear domain.
KYLE SIMPSON: But as a package
owner myself, I author code,
and I'm constantly
getting requests to, hey,
can you add the new bower.json?
And then when a new one comes,
will you please-- you know,
it's a full request to add that.
And then it's a maintenance
overhead for me.
I know there are
tools that can manage.
JOSH PEEK: I totally agree
with what you're saying,
and I think the way
that we need to solve
this is I think if we
can actually standardize
on the metadata format, and
all get on package JSON,
then we don't have to have
a [INAUDIBLE] base in there.
But that means-- that also
means having npm give up,
like, full control over
what package JSON is.
LAURIE VOSS: So npm
is already incredibly
loosey-goosey about
what package JSON is.
We have a schemaless
database, for better or worse,
so anything that you put in
package JSON gets in there
and is indexable and
replicates to the entire world.
So people-- a lot of
the stuff that npm does
arrived there by accident.
People just started
putting in their main disc,
they started putting in the
files thing, they started--
JOSH PEEK: Like Browserify?
LAURIE VOSS: Right.
They just started adding
stanzas to package updates
and eventually were like,
well, that cow path seem
OK, let's pave it.
JOSH PEEK: I think if we had
some sort of community effort
to standardize how these
metadata fields work,
I think there's a lot in common
between all of these package
tools.
Again, this is more
from, like, OK,
so the-- if we can decide
how package JSON works, then
you can have other
sorts of build
tools that understand
package JSON.
And that can, I
think, really help
other communities that
aren't doing no js.
Like, there's still tons of
Java people writing web servers,
and they want to use
front end packages so.
KYLE SIMPSON: But
in all fairness,
rather than putting a Bower
field into package JSON,
they created a separate file.
And in fact, how
can we stop that
from happening with all the
other specialized package
managers?
JOSH PEEK: Well, again, I think
that's getting people on board.
And, like, what do we
share in common and,
like, how do we actually
extend this for,
like, other-- I
think getting back
to the question about
the build tools thing--
I don't want to go too
much into build tools--
but I think there is an
overlap in the manifest of how
do build tools interoperate
with these metadata fields.
DOMINIC DENICOLA: And to
me, my favorite example
of this, the easiest one, is if
you're building a web component
and distributing
it on npm and you
want to reserve a tag
name, you should probably,
like, somebody should
take the lead and say,
the standard here is put
a tag name, x flip box,
in your package JSON.
And then, if you see two x
flip boxes in the project,
you're like, oh, shit.
OK.
My build tool needs to
do something about this
or my tooling needs to
do something about this.
And probably we wouldn't
bake that into npm,
it's not really--
shouldn't necessarily need
to be aware of web components,
but it's a strong convention.
And if we as a community
can agree on that, or even
just a large starter community,
whether it be Polymer
or whatever, that
would be a great start.
MATT MILLER: Just to play
devil's advocate a little bit--
KYLE SIMPSON: Before you do,
let's make sure we queue up.
[INAUDIBLE] and Rachel have
some comments from the floor.
So go ahead.
MATT MILLER: So, at
least from my experience,
I think some of
this stuff could be
solved with, like, the separate
ecosystems and possibly
a standardized format.
But from my position,
a lot of times
when you go to a
repository, you have
no idea does this work
on the client side,
does this work on
the server side?
And so it's kind
of nice, actually,
like, having two manifests.
Like, especially one that's
like component.json or something
like that where you're like, OK,
I know this is going to work.
Or like a Bower.
Like, I know this
is going to work.
Or it's meant to work on
the client side versus this
could possibly
work on the server,
and it might work
in the browser, too.
LAURIE VOSS: If there was
just component-- sorry.
DAVID BECK: I hope we're going
towards a world where it's
clear-- which package
manager you use
is clear based on the nature
of your package, in which case
there really shouldn't
be-- I mean the overlap,
it may be coincidental,
but it's not
guaranteed that they're going
to be the same fields that
are important.
I mean, ideally there--
KYLE SIMPSON: There
does feel like there's
a lot of overlap right now.
DAVID BECK: There is
a lot of overlap right
now, especially in
that space where
you have JavaScript client side
packages with other assets,
which is a huge space right now.
I mean, it's Ember, it's
Backbone, it's Angular,
to some degree.
All of those are
JavaScript logic
that have additional
resources on them.
And not only that,
but it's hugely
valuable for an
internal application
to structure their application
in such a modularized way,
and also for sharing
with package manager.
So there's a huge potential
there to get a lot of value
from standardizing
some of this stuff.
KYLE SIMPSON: [INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: So my
question goes back
to basically
understanding two things.
One is, what is the exact
role of specialty client side
package managers?
And back to the
question of a standard--
KYLE SIMPSON: I want to remind
that we want to save questions
for the breakout
session so can you
share an opinion about this?
How it's difficult
specifically for you?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So when I think about client
side package managers,
I mean, traditionally
you can think of HTML
and browser itself
as a package manager,
just specify your resources
in your HTML with proper URLs.
You reference, like, different
CDNs with different versions
of jQuery and
whatever, and you get
your package kind
of for deployment.
But now for my client side,
especially package managers,
they seem to be mostly
focused on build only
and build in terms
of download something
from somewhere else
on my local machine
so that I have a
repeatable process.
Now that it's on
my machine, I can
apply some skips over whatever
and then deploy that way.
So I think if you clarify
what exactly is the flow
and where they fit in this
flow and what they provide,
a lot of these questions
could answered.
Otherwise, just using
package managers
for installing and
deploying stuff,
I see a lot of overlapping.
If you go especially
with the standardization,
HTML and manifest is
one of the attempts
that they had for
standardizing--
KYLE SIMPSON: So I know
you have a disagreement
in that definition of
what package managers do.
So clarify for us.
DOMINIC DENICOLA: Yeah.
I mean, so I think
what I'm hearing
is you're thinking, how is this
different from our script tag
world, right?
And I think it's different
in a few key ways.
First of all, it's reproducible.
You're not depending on
somebody's external URL
to have the same content
there from day-to-day.
Second, it takes care of
dependencies for you, right?
So if I include Backbone
and it needs underscore,
that needs to get taken
care of for me instead of,
hey, put these two script
tags or these five script tags
or these 20 script
tags in your head.
And third, it's just
like, it's a way
of getting it all tied
together into one flow
where you're like
npm install Ember,
and all these things
get installed.
And then you have a
build tool or maybe you
do script tags like
you do with Bower.
You put those in
your head or wherever
or use a module system, right?
But the important thing is
it takes care of dependencies
for you, and I
think that's really
what a package manager is
about more so than the world
where you just do script tags.
KYLE SIMPSON: It seems like one
of the most important pieces
of metadata that can possibly
exist is the version number.
So we're going to transition
to a specific question
about version numbers and
about semantic versioning.
So the recent controversy
over semantic versioning
asks whether or not
it's even reasonable
to have meaningful and
interoperable version numbers.
What must we all do to
bring sanity to this space?
And I'll throw it to
specifically to Dominic.
Are we at edge 4.0 or edge 0.4?
DOMINIC DENICOLA: Oh, man.
OK.
So 0.x versions are an
unfortunate situation
where I think it's just
because npm for a long time
had zero as their default for
your starting where people
were like, oh, I'll publish 0.x.
And then semver.org is like,
0.x doesn't mean semantic,
it could change at any time.
And that's a whole
mess, but I do
think kind of getting to the
larger question of semantics
and versions and what we can
do, I think if we as a community
can agree to SemVer,
that enables some really
powerful abilities,
especially on the client side.
Because if you have two packages
using Ember 1.x and 2.x, then
you need to know, OK, this is
not going to work together.
Right?
Or maybe it does if
it's something smaller,
like date format or
library 1.x and 2.x.
That will work together.
Right?
But you need the ability
to have this insight
into what are the conflicts?
And if you don't use
semantic versioning,
then you have no way of
kind of automating that.
You can't say, oh, well,
this guy needs Ember 1.--
or let's do Backbone.
This guy needs Backbone 1.6,
and this guy needs Backbone 1.7.
Now I have to remember that
Backbone doesn't follow
semantic versioning so I
can't actually coalesce those,
I have to say, oh,
there's a conflict.
Whereas if it's something
that does follow
semantic versioning, you can see
those conflicts more clearly.
So I guess-- I mean, it's
hard to give an answer of just
we should all do SemVer, because
I think the question is kind
of asking, like, SemVer never,
worked so what's going on?
But--
KYLE SIMPSON: Is the git commit
tag a universal versions?
Can we just standardize
on that and get rid
of semantic versions?
JOSH PEEK: No.
I think you use
Ember and get tags.
LAURIE VOSS: The problem with
SemVer is that everyone thinks
they know what SemVer
is and they don't.
When you get to the
edge cases the split
between how-- when
it's ambiguous,
the split between the
cases is nearly 50-50,
and that's the problem.
Like, if we could
agree what SemVer was,
then it would be great.
And we agree for about
90% of use cases,
and the final 10%, which is
where all the problems happen,
there's no consensus at all.
KYLE SIMPSON: It seems
like the 0.x is really
the biggest area of confusion.
So can you provide
some clarity on that?
LAURIE VOSS: So it depends what
you think should happen, right?
The way that npm as of 2.0.0,
which was released last week.
Everyone should download it.
The way that it
works is basically
the most significant digit is
considered the major version.
So if you are point
0.0.1, then 0.0.1
is considered
incompatible with 0.0.2.
But if you're 0.1.1,
then 0.1.1 and 0.1.2
are considered minor features.
KYLE SIMPSON: I'm
already completely lost.
Anybody else?
LAURIE VOSS: Right.
Whereas everybody is fairly
clear once you're in 1.0,
that 1.0 to 2.0 is
a breaking change.
1.1 to 1.2 is a feature change.
And 1.1.2 to 1.1.3
is a minor change.
KYLE SIMPSON: So does 0.x
just need to go away entirely?
LAURIE VOSS: That is sort
of-- we changed the default.
We changed npm in it to
create all packages at 1.0.0
simply because 0.x was so
confusing to everybody.
Just start at 1.0.
Like, integers are free.
You can use as many
of them as you like.
KYLE SIMPSON: Excellent.
MATT MILLER: What are
your guys' thoughts on,
like, simplifying the, like,
tilde versus caret verses
all those?
Like, what's up with that?
KYLE SIMPSON: Version ranges
for those of you who don't know.
LAURIE VOSS: We have a
lot of lively discussions
about that in the office.
The point of introducing
the caret range was to try
and clarify the
semantics of the tilde,
which were in turn to try
and clarify the semantics
of the .x, x which is what
everyone was using before that.
Everyone understands
what .x does.
It's like, that x is a variable.
And tilde means, like,
minor versions are OK.
And caret is supposed to
mean feature versions are OK
but not breaking
changes, which is great
if you understand
those semantics.
And then as soon as
you get into the 0.x,
people are like,
oh, but I thought
this was a feature change.
In turns out that it's
a breaking change.
And it all goes to hell.
So again, pass 1.0, tilde
versus caret is pretty easy.
And before zero it's
just a hell scape
from which no one will escape.
MATT MILLER: Got ya.
DOMINIC DENICOLA:
So I think what's
really interesting is one
of my friend, Yehuda Katz,
is doing the cargo
package manager for Rust.
And he has the benefit of
being greenfield, right?
This is a very new
package manager.
His semantics are,
you don't have
any of these crazy
punctuations, but it always
follows semantic versioning.
So if you put 1.2.3
in your package
or your cargo [INAUDIBLE]?
Seriously [INAUDIBLE].
If you put it in
there, then you won't
get anything in the one series
that is greater than 1.2.3,
which is great.
You don't have to
remember any of this;
it just follows
semantic versioning.
And then what he
does is if you really
need to pin it, which is
an important capability
if somebody's being badly
behaved, you do = 1.2.3.
So I kind of wish that we
could just rewind the clock
and use those semantics
instead of inventing
all these punctuations,
but it's just something
to be wistful about, I guess.
KYLE SIMPSON: Matt,
what do you think?
Are the version numbers that
you deal with in your software,
are they easy for
you to reason about
as well as those that
consume your software?
MATT MILLER: I would
say for the most part.
I'm-- personally, I'm confused
about the tildes and the carets
and stuff and when you
should use them and when you
shouldn't--
LAURIE VOSS: I get them
wrong all the time.
MATT MILLER: Yeah.
KYLE SIMPSON: I think that's
one of the reasons why,
like, for instance when
the underscore controversy
happened, I think that's one
of the arguments that was made
is if it's that
complex, maybe we
need to find a simpler system.
MATT MILLER: Yeah.
And you have a dash beta,
beta 2, beta 3, beta 4.
Like, it's really-- it seems
a little bit overly complex,
and maybe there's
reason for that.
But maybe we should
reevaluate the whole system.
DOMINIC DENICOLA: And I think
there is a good reason, which
is the reduplication, right?
So if I depend on ^1.2.3 and the
other person depends on ^1.4.0,
we should be able to install
1.4.2 and both of us use that.
And that's a great benefit.
So that's the plus.
I mean, I agree it's complex,
but it does have payoffs.
KYLE SIMPSON: Do version
numbers for packages
become kind of like they
are for browsers, which
are just arbitrary marketing
labels at that point?
DAVID BECK: Well, ideally not.
I mean--
DOMINIC DENICOLA: So
browsers are perpetually
stuck on SemVer 1.0.
And in fact, the entire
web is perpetually
stuck on SemVer 1.0.
You cannot make backwards
breaking changes in a browser
so browser version
numbers are arbitrary just
because otherwise we would
always be incrementing, like,
the patch or the feature.
And that's kind of-- nobody
wants to be Firefox 1.37.43.
LAURIE VOSS: The most
compelling use case
for semantic
versioning and having
some sort of way of dealing with
that problem is the security
case.
When people say,
I have this thing,
and the only-- or the bug case.
I have this package, and
the only change I've made
is that it doesn't,
like, expose all
of your data to the
universe anymore.
I promise, that's the
only thing I've changed.
You want a way for
a you as an author
to be able to communicate
that safely to the world.
That's what the minor
versions are for.
If that's the only thing
that you get out of SemVer,
that's hugely valuable.
Like, npm install
this except not as
broken as it was last time.
That is a great feature.
KYLE SIMPSON: All right.
I think we can continue
in the breakout session
a lot more on this, but
I want to transition
to our next question a
topic about documentation.
So if we can all agree on
the importance of package
documentation, I
mean, relatively,
because different people
feel stronger or less
strongly about it.
But if we can all agree
that it is important,
how can package
managers do a better job
of encouraging and
maybe even rewarding
discoverable documentation
for all their packages?
LAURIE VOSS: So we have
a good answer here, too.
Again, one of the new
features of the new website
was this was one of the
things that kept coming up
is that what is
the readme.md for?
Do we want there to be a
documentation directory?
Do we want to, like, descend
from the heavens and say,
this is how you do
the documentation.
It should be in this format.
Like, somebody came
along and said,
you should specify that
there's, like, a JavaScript doc.
Like, Java doc.
And we were like, no.
But we do want to, like you
said, reward good behavior.
So one of the things
that we are going
to be doing in
the new website is
we're going to be saying
that if you have written
your readme.md within
this format such
that we can recognize it, it
will become more than just,
like, a solid wall of text.
If you have said that
this is an example,
then we will put your
example in a special place.
If you have said that this is
your index, this is your spec,
this is your API, like, we will
treat those things specially
and we will allow you to
search for those things.
And we will display them
better and stuff like that.
So we think we
should reward that.
But there is a line
to be drawn, which
is at some point your
documentation site becomes
a website, and we do not want
to become like a generic tool
for generating a
documentation website.
There are lots of
tools for that.
KYLE SIMPSON: Of
course there are
plenty of tools that have
created centralized things,
but I mean, I want
to push back and say,
isn't linking to the read me
kind of just the bare minimum?
Isn't there a lot
more on the table
that we should be
doing to encourage
much more diverse documentation?
LAURIE VOSS: There is.
But like I said,
you have to-- we
want to draw a line somewhere.
We want to say that
there is a difference
between the
explanation of what it
is that it does with
the basic examples
and the full documentation
website, which
is a complicated thing.
Like, for express,
you don't want
to have-- we don't want to
build the entire documentation
of express into the npm
website because it would be--
the amount of complexity
there is just too much.
DOMINIC DENICOLA:
Or like jQuery.
The jQuery doc site is
great, and I look up
my functions there.
And I don't really want an
iframe in npm.org/jquery that
has the jQuery website.
That seems pointless.
DAVID BECK: Isn't this all tied
back to the overall quality
of the module?
I mean, by pushing people to
the top who have good ratings,
it seems like this is kind of
taken care of in user land,
if you will.
One thing that always
has kind of-- I
felt like it's a
loose end of npm
is how it has it's
separate rating system,
and then you go to
GitHub and it's like,
oh, there's another star rating.
It'd be cool-- I'd like to see
those two things come together
so it's, like, simplified.
KYLE SIMPSON: Let's
queue up [INAUDIBLE]
to give a comment
from the crowd.
Go ahead, sorry.
LAURIE VOSS: Sorry.
Exactly that is happening.
People keep saying to us,
like, there are npm stars
and there are GitHub stars.
What is the difference
between those two?
And the answer is, when
we invented npm stars,
GitHub stars didn't exist.
GitHub, at one point, split from
stars into stars and watchers,
and then the semantics
of stars became clear.
But npm stars predate that.
So the new npm
website is basically
going to turn npm stars into
something more like bookmarks
and say that the stars
are the GitHub stars.
That's what everyone believes
But the wrinkle is
that it penalizes
people who don't use
GitHub, and there
are-- you know, that's
10% of the registry.
KYLE SIMPSON: OK.
AUDIENCE: Perhaps to
help with the question,
I'm actually challenging
the question itself.
There's a big difference between
package managers and package
repositories.
And I think npm kind of
serves both worlds there
and it's kind of the
unique situation.
Like Bower, for example.
Bower is the package
manager, but their repository
is actually GitHub.
So when it comes to
questions like star ratings
or documentation, are
we trying to answer
that with package managers?
Or are we trying to answer
that with repositories?
LAURIE VOSS: Yeah.
You're asking for a
feature of the registry
there, which something
like Bower can't do,
unless I'm mistaken.
Like, you could not have
Bower stars or Bower ratings.
DAVID BECK: No.
It's all in GitHub.
KYLE SIMPSON: OK.
Let's move to the
next question then.
What specific functionality
can package managers
offer that supports the specific
concerns of CSS and HTML
and even other asset types
given their lack of modules?
DAVID BECK: I think
it's very simple.
That's my perspective.
I think it's a sticky
area, but it's very simple
to basically support the
skeleton of what you need,
which is basically an inventory
of the other asset types.
If we're talking
about JavaScript
packages where your core
dependencies and your flow
is going through
your JavaScript.
That's your principal
object, and then you
have these add on CSS and
maybe fonts or images.
All you need is an
enumeration of which
of those things in
your repository--
DOMINIC DENICOLA: So we
call that the file system.
Right?
Like, there is a file system,
and it contains an enumeration
of all the things
in your package.
DAVID BECK: If that's
what everybody agrees on,
then that's what it is.
Or another option was to be--
to explicitly list them out
in package.json.
I know you're not a fan of
that, but it doesn't really
matter which one as much
as it being defined.
And one of the big things
that package managers are
responsible for is the
metadata that we've
talked about a lot of the time.
So if it's not defined
anywhere, and it's not
defined in the
metadata, then it's
really hard to deal with
these [INAUDIBLE] assets.
DOMINIC DENICOLA:
There's a difference
between metadata and data.
I think this is data; I
don't think it's metadata.
KYLE SIMPSON: But we
need to talk specifically
about why CSS and HTML
aren't as well suited
for this as JavaScript is.
LAURIE VOSS: So you
touched-- so, Dave,
you touched on this earlier.
The fundamental
problem of CSS and HTML
as a package
manager and what npm
should do it if it decides
to support CSS and HTML is
that you can't use node module
semantics to resolve conflicts.
Node modules can be put into
the node modules directory,
and there's an algorithm
that works perfectly
to make sure that conflicting
version don't conflict.
And it's one of the
best things about node.
And CSS and HTML
don't work that way.
If you declare reset.css
and your HTML's
looking for it in the route,
there can only be one of those.
And as a package
manager you have
to make the decision is the
behavior that my users expect,
is the thing that
we should be doing
saying that if you try to
install two packages that
declare the same asset,
should they conflict?
Should I die?
Should I stop?
Or should I say that there's
some other-- you know,
I do some crazy
rewrite so that they
can exist at the same time.
And that I go down into
the HTML, and like,
you spiral away into this
very complicated world.
DAVID BECK: You're assuming
that one, that npm or-- you're
assuming things about
the build process.
That namespace doesn't
have to be flat
so that there's only
one space for reset.css.
It doesn't have to be.
And I don't think
that's something
that npm needs to
get involved in.
I think it's better
that it doesn't.
KYLE SIMPSON: Well, that's
a lot more intrusive
to the development
process, right?
Because that's how
you decide to put
your IDs in your CSS or
[INAUDIBLE] and things
like that.
DAVID BECK: Yeah.
There are conflicts
in semantics of CSS,
and, yeah, those
are unavoidable.
There are two files that
declare the same class name
and they target the
same element and they
target in different
ways, your web page
is going to look screwed up.
But that's the way it is.
There's no way to solve it.
MATT MILLER: And what
about just providing--
DAVID BECK: It's like
peer dependencies.
It's like a little bit
of evil, but it's OK.
MATT MILLER: It's a
little bit like you said.
I think, like, the biggest
indicator is your web site
looks screwed up, right?
And so I think how do you
resolve this screwed up state?
I think, like, maybe better
tooling might be the way to go.
You say, like, duplicates--
npm duplicates or something
like that.
And you notice, oh,
there's two resets.
Or, oh, there's two
bootstraps here.
Now I have to go investigate and
figure out what the issue is.
I don't know.
DAVID BECK: I don't
think the conflicts are
going to be that extensive.
I feel like the packages that
do a poor job of targeting--
I mean, bootstrap, I think,
is a slightly different thing.
I don't really
think that bootstrap
should be handled inside
of npm anyways, being CSS.
But if you have a
JavaScript component
the targets a
specific CSS element
and it does it badly, in
a way that it conflicts
with other stuff, then it's not
going to get very good ratings
and hopefully not many people
will use it and you know--
KYLE SIMPSON: OK.
Well, that's a wrap.
I appreciate all the panelists.
I just want to remind
you again we're
going to have the breakout,
and the big question
that we're going to tackle there
is what happens when somebody
compromises one of these
packets repositories?
So come and check
us out in there.
All right, thank you very much.
Appreciate it.